Let's have a closer look at how methods are described in javadoc. Here is an
example. Before the parenthesis you have the name of the method, in this case
pixels. Before the name, you have the type of the return value. In this case,
that's int because the pixels method returns the number of pixels in an image
as an integer since you can't have half a pixel. Let's look at another example,
the grow method. Again, the name is before the parentheses and before that is
the return type but in this case, remember the grow method doesn't return
anything and we use this special word void to denote that. Void means that
nothing is returned. Now this method call has another feature. It describes
what kind of arguments to pass. You call this method with two arguments and
here you find the types you can grow by any decimal number. It doesn't have to
be an integer. Now actually and that's a minor detail, that you don't really
need to think about until the next lesson. What you see inside here, the double
dw and the double dh are themselves variable declarations. They declare two
variables that are called the parameter variables. Like I said, right now you
don't yet have to worry about the parameter variables but when you see the word
parameters in javadoc, then you'll know where that comes from. Now you know all
the technical terms that you need to decipher a javadoc documentation.